A thrilling new teaser trailer for upcoming
Disney+ series The Mandalorian has arrived,
and it gives us our first look at Ming-Na
Wen's mysterious assassin character.
The 30-second clip consists mostly of previously
seen footage – including sweeping looks
at the Outer Rim's landscapes and the Mandalorian's
weaponry and clothes, as well as a few of
the creatures, ships, people, and battles
he'll face.
At one point in the new teaser trailer, the
Mandalorian appears before a group of aliens
and humans.
Among them is Carl Weathers' Greef Carga,
whom we know works with the Mandalorian and
heads up a bounty hunter guild.
The trailer also sees the return of several
scout troopers on speeder bikes, plus the
Taika Waititi-voiced IG-11 rapidly spinning
and unleashing a burst of plasma energy shots
around it.
The crowning moment of the new Mandalorian
teaser trailer, however, is a brief but punchy
exchange that sees Agents of S.H.I.E.L.D.
actress Ming-Na Wen deliver a single, goosebumps-inducing
line to the titular character.
"Your name will be legendary."
It's a funny nod to the fan-favorite villain-esque
Boba Fett, who wore almost identical armor
to the new Disney+ series character.
But, as showrunner Jon Favreau has clarified,
Fett wasn't an actual Mandalorian and Pedro
Pascal's character is.
Up to this point, not much has been revealed
about Ming-Na Wen's character, Fennec Shand.
In an interview with Vanity Fair, Wen revealed
several details about her role.
Wen described the gun-toting mercenary as
similar to Han Solo in that she starts with
no beliefs in any causes but her own.
According to Wen:
"We got our inspiration really from the name.
The idea of a fennec fox came to mind.
I just love that whole image with the name."
Fennec's original concept design apparently
gave her a more disheveled look, but she appears
in the new Mandalorian trailer as much more
put-together.
That's due to Wen, who had a hand in shaping
her character's appearance to be more fitting
of the fox imagery.
Wen said:
"At first, the idea was maybe just have her
hair be loose, unkempt kind of thing.
'And I thought, well, she's going to be wearing
a helmet and she's this stealth assassin.
How great would it be if her hair has a bit
of the fennec fox architecture to it?'
So the hairstylist came up with this great
braiding system, that just gives an idea of
these triangular points.
Like her ears."
Due to the darkness of the shot in the trailer
in which Fennec appears, you can't quite see
the more intricate elements of Fennec's hairstyle,
but Wen revealed that her braid will be threaded
with orange strands as a callback to her character's
fox inspiration.
Expect her outfits to feature these color
elements as well.
According to Wen:
"The designer, Joseph [Porro], came up with
this amazing outfit that I fell in love with
right away.
It's black, but then there's the fennec orange
punch to it.
So that's kind of like her brand, I guess."
While we've got a peek at Fennec Shand now,
fans will have to wait a bit to see her make
her first appearance on The Mandalorian.
Wen confirmed that her character and the Mandalorian
aren't slated to cross paths until around
halfway through the first season.
On the upside, the new trailer for The Mandalorian
did manage to deliver more about another previously
teased character, voiced by Nick Nolte: an
Ugnaught named, uh...
Quill?
Koo-will?
Kanye?
Anyway, past previews have offered silent
glimpses of the alien riding a blurrg - a
two-legged creature that looks sort of like
a fish-dinosaur hybrid - but this is the first
time we've heard this guy talk.
The Mandalorian, the first live-action Star
Wars TV show, also stars Giancarlo Esposito
as interstellar administrator Moff Gideon
and Gina Carano as former Rebel Shock Trooper
Cara Dune.
Plus, Werner Herzog as an imperial agent,
Bill Burr as a bounty hunter, and Julia Jones
as a character presently known only as Omera.
The Disney+ series will premiere on November
12.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.